[Music]
why are these crocodiles spending so
much time on dry land is it because
their watery homes are too polluted or
is it because they're scared of a bigger
predator lurking in the water an ancient
dinosaur that we thought was long gone
but it never left meet the Spinosaurus
it's more massive than the Tyrannosaurus
Rex
likes to swim and loves to eat anything
that enters its territory if humans had
been living alongside these River
Monsters all along how different what
our lives have been this is what if and
here's what would happen if the
Spinosaurus never went extinct the
Spinosaurus lived about 95 million years
ago with a body length of 14 to 18
meters and an estimated mass of 12,000
to 20,000 kilograms it was the largest
predator the Nile has ever seen if it
had somehow managed to avoid the
extinction of the dinosaurs it would
still be swimming there
and Egypt would have never developed to
be what it is today would ancient
Egyptians still have been able to rely
on the Nile River for food and
transportation would they have found a
way to coexist with the giant river
monsters or would they have fought them
to the death the Spinosaurus had a long
tail that produced a higher thrust and
was more efficient in the water than the
tail shapes of other dinosaurs this made
them very hard to escape from in the
water but they were not as threatening
on land because they were pretty clumsy
and not well adapted to it so if we
lived in a world where the Spinosaurus
still existed then all we'd have to do
is stay out of their water and we'd be
safe right not exactly
we wouldn't be the only ones to fear
these giant dinosaurs today lots of
crocodiles live along the Nile River
if the Spinosaurus had survived the mass
extinction and still lived in the Nile
today the crocodiles would be looking
for a new home on land and if crocodiles
became land dwellers the land along the
Nile would look very different too
crocodiles might eat small mammals and
humans would need to be more aware of
their surroundings to protect themselves
from the crocodiles as bad as an
increase in crocodile encounter sounds
it wouldn't be the most significant
change we'd experience in a world with
Spinosaurus Egypt's history and social
evolution could have been very different
ancient Egyptian culture relied on the
Nile River and if this large semi
aquatic dinosaur was roaming around they
might not have been able to use it as
much or at least they would have needed
a way to protect themselves from the
giant dinosaur
hunting the Spinosaurus wouldn't have
been easy but it would have been
necessary if northern African
communities wanted a steady supply of
fish to eat the practice would have
become so important to the people's
survival that hieroglyphics would
probably have had drawings of the
dinosaur and
how the Egyptians captured and killed
them over the years in true human form
we would probably have started hunting
the Spinosaurus for sport and fashion
you think crocodile boots are cool
wait until you see Spinosaurus sandals
maybe we would even have hunted them so
much that they'd be on the brink of
extinction and what then would they
become a protected species or would we
all be happy to see them disappear well
before you go making save the
Spinosaurus signs just remember that
none of this is really likely to have
happened the Spinosaurus probably died
from the mass extinction event that
wiped out the dinosaurs if it didn't it
would have quickly gone extinct soon
after because of the lack of food there
would have been massive competition for
food between Spinosaurus since the
environment was more favorable for small
creatures that didn't need as much food
but that's probably a good thing even if
it might have been cool to live with
Dinosaurs
if these huge dinosaurs were still
living they would have changed evolution
in Africa we might have had different
fish land animals and ancient
civilizations that were adapted for
living alongside these massive creatures
maybe even our bodies would have evolved
to become different but that's a story
for another what if
[Music]